[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: I'm in Dar
Es Salaam, Tanzania.
And everywhere we
go, we see people
carrying some crazy
things on their heads.
And they do it so effortlessly
it is very impressive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've seen so many women
carrying things on their heads--
big boxes, buckets.
Why do people carry so
many things on their heads?
WOMEN: [SPEAKING SWAHILI]
INTERPRETER: They're saying
it's the culture from the girls.
They have grown up carrying
things on their head.
LAURA LING: It's
part of the culture.
Is it difficult?
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING SWAHILI]
WOMEN: [SPEAKING SWAHILI]
LAURA LING: Easy?
Can you teach me?
Can you show me?
Can I try?
OK.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING SWAHILI]
LAURA LING: So what
do I need to know?
Any advice?
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING SWAHILI]
WOMEN: [SPEAKING SWAHILI]
INTERPRETER: They are
saying, just leave it.
LAURA LING: Just leave it?
Let go with my hands?
OK, and relax.
Ready?
I'm going to do it.
INTERPRETER: Wow.
WOMEN: Wow.
LAURA LING: Good?
LAURA LING: I got it!
I got it.
[LAUGHTER]
Good?
[SAYS THANK YOU IN SWAHILI]
Thank you for teaching me.
Please check out
this next video.
It's Saturday night here
in Mkuranga, Tanzania.
And we're going to do
with the locals do.
We're going to go to the movies
at the local movie theater.
Most people in this town
don't have electricity,
so they come here
for entertainment.
Luckily, this place
has a generator.
Thanks for watching and be sure
to subscribe to Seeker Stories.
[MUSIC PLAYING]